‏ja
الله اكبر لا اله الا الله اعتدلوا استووا
سووا الصف سدوا
الخلل الله رب
العالمين الرحم المغضوب عليه ولا الضام
الى المسجد الاقصى الذي باركنا
حوله لنريه من
اياتنا ان السميع
البصير واتينا موسى الكتاب وجعلنا الا
تتخذوا من دوني
وكيلا ذريه من حملنا مع نوح انه كان
عبدا
شكورا وقضينا الى بني
اسرائيل في الكتاب
لتفسدن في الارض
مرتين
لتفسدن
فيرا وكان ان
احسنتم
للكافرين
حصيرا
الله الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم تقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضال
ين
امين ان هذا القران يهدي للتي هي اقوم
ويبشر
المؤمنين ويبشر المؤمنين الذين يعملون
الصالحات ان لهم اجرا
كبيرا ان الذين لا يؤمنون
بالاخره اعتدنا لهم عذابا
اليما ويدعوا
الانسان بالشر
دعاءه
بالخير وكان
الانسان
عجولا وجعلنا الليل
والنه
ايتين فمحونا ايه الليل وجعلنا ايه النهار
مبصره لتبتغوا
فضلا من ربكم
ولتعلموا ولتعلموا عدد السنين
والحساب وكل
شيء
تفصيلا
وكل
انسان الزمناه
طا ضلين
حتى واذا كان كان يريد العاجله
عجلنا
نريد
ثمت وسع
لك الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر سمع
الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله الله الله
[Silence]
اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
[Silence]
السلام
‏var di
office
استقيموا اعتدلوا
[Silence]
استووا الله
اكبر الرحمن رحيم
عليهم غير
الموا الاما افغير
ربقا اما تعرضك ولا تبسطها كه كان
بعباده خبيرا
واياكم ان قتلهم كان
خطا
كبيرا لا تقرب الزن
وساء
سبيلا ولا تقت قتل مظلوما فقد جعلنا لوليه
سلطانا ف ولا تقربوا مال اليتيم الا بالتي
هي احسن حتى اذا كلتم وزنوا بالقسطاس
المسقف ما ليس لك به علم
ان السمع عنه
مسؤولا ولا تمش في الارض
مرحا
انك لن تخرق الارض ولن تبلغ الجبال
طولا كل كل ذلك كان سييه عند
ربك ذرا قولا
عظيما ولقد صرفنا في هذا القران
ليذكر وما يزيدهم الا
طغيانا
كبيرا وما يزيدهم الا
نفورا قل لو كان معه
الهه كما
يقولون
اذا لا ابتغوا الى ذي العرش
سبيلا سبحانه وتعالى عما يقولون
علوا
كبيرا تسبح له السماوات السبع والارض ومن
فيهن الا يسبح بحمده ولكن لا تفقهون
تسبيحهم
انه كان حليما
غفورا واذا اخره حجابا
مستورا وجعل القران والعلم بما يستمعون به
اذ يستمعون اليك واذ هم
نجوى اذ يقولوا الظالمون ان تتبعون الا
رجلا
مسحورا انظر كيف ضربوا لك الامثال
فضلوا فضلوا فلا
يستطيعون
سبيلا الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضال
امين وقالوا ائذا كنا عظاما ورفاه اان
لمبره او
حديدا او خلقا و مره فس
فتستجيبون بحمده
وتظنون
ينزغ
بينهم
ارحمكم ولقد فضلنا ولا تح رحمته
ويخاف اولئك الذين يدعون يبتغون الى ربهم
الوسيله وان من قريه الكتاب ما فعد
واتينا
ثمودا ناق
تفع واتينا ثمود الناقه مبصره
فظلموا بها وما نرسل
بالايات الا
تخويفا واذ قلنا لك ان ربك احاط بالناس
وما جعلنا الرؤيا التي اريناك الا
فتنه
الا في القران ونخ اسجد لمن خ ان
جهنم فان واستفزز معدهم والبحر لتبتغوا
لتبتغوا
مياه فلما نجاكم
حاصبا ثم لا ان يعيدكم فيه تاره
ريح
ثم
فيغرق
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
السلام
اوكي
الله اكبر
العالمين المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضال واذا مسكم الضر في البحر
ضل
افامن ام
امنتم ان يعيدكم فيه تاره اخرى فيرسل
عليكم قاص علينا به
تبيعا ولقد كر
الطيبات
ورزقناهم من الطيبات
وفضلنا كتابه بيمينه
فاول
فاولئك
يقراون كتابهم ولا يظلمون
فتيلا
ومن كان في هذه اعمى فهو في الاخره اعمى
واضل
سبيلا وان كادوا ليفتنونك علينا
نصيرا وان كادوا ليستفزونك من ليفتنونك عن
الذي اوحينا اليك لتفتري عليه
غيره واذا لاتخذوك خك ضعف الحياه واخرجو
من اقمصه لك عسى ان يبعثك ربك
مقاما
محمودا وقل رب ادخلني مدخل صدق واخرجني
مخرج صدق واجعل لي من لدن جاء الحق وزهق
ال طل ان الباطل كان
زهوقا وننزل من القران ما هو
شفاء واذا ان اعلم بمن وبك ان
ظهيرا افجر لنا من الارض من نخيل وعنب ف
زخرف او ترقى اذ جاون مطمئن ان كان بعباده
خبيرا
بصيرا ومن يهدي الله فهو
المهتد ومن يضلل فلن تجد لهم
اولياء من دونه ونحن